welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of rick and
morty season 4 episode 9
childrek of mort the episode that
literally killed god
or a zeus named reggie by accident but
also acknowledges the existence of the
real god
it was just a real rollercoaster of
blasphemy and monotheism
i'm actually going to kill two gods with
one stone this week and break down all
the episode's subtle animation jokes
and explain the deeper agenda of this
episode and a little later i'm going to
go even deeper into the episode
with voice actor nolan north yes okay
the episode's titled childrek of mort is
a nod to children of men
the amazing apostle choir owned film in
which clive owen becomes an
unlikely surrogate father figure to the
last pregnant woman in a
post-apocalyptic fertility
crisis world now the plot is quite
different from this episode of rick and
morty but
thematically rick too learns the lesson
of paternal responsibility
rick's god-level ego means his exes are
macro-sized from a hive mind race and
autoerotic assimilation
to now a whole living planet named gaia
similar to ego the living planet from
marvel but her name
gaia has roots to greek mythology the
kind of personification of mother earth
actually come to think there's also a
gaia or gaia in marvel see folks if
there's something to rip off from
mythology comics have done it
like season three's ninth episode this
season four ninth episode focuses on
rick
and beth's relationship beth forces rick
to finally be a good parent to the clay
children
in order to redeem his absent parenting
to her but the noble parental goals
devolve into a
petty ego battle between gods and
between their mortal champions
that leaves the youth of this episode
scarred and broken
it's a moral that's typically cynical on
the show parents deepest motivation is
actually their egotistical vain
childish whims of the gods of mythology
and the old testament
my kids must be in my image and someday
i'll abandon them
summer begins the episode feeling fomo
for a stupid spring break party
i'm missing mike trisket's drug party
look at this he's already watching
euphoria in a pregame
mike triscuit which is how dumb the
names of all friends of teenagers sound
has a glow stick necklace as they're
grammy about watching hbo's euphoria
i hate these kids rick tries to block
out gaia's seismic texts
why are you building a faraday box to
block out the signal faraday box or
faraday cage
blocks out electromagnetic signals
that's why rick tests it with an
electromagnet i love that he had this
folded up and ready to go
summer calls rick a boy which jerry
fails to repeat
at least we know why rick actually came
on the trip to avoid his
guy problem and this has been pointed
out in past seasons but the smith family
car is modeled on the green and wood
paneled station wagon driven by the
griswolds in national lampoon's vacation
rick reveals i [ __ ] the planet and on
the surface he paraphrases neil
armstrong
sex with a living planet big step for
mankind the sight of this conception is
a huge crater which is especially gross
when you realize
gaia's previous partner was the zeus
reggie who caused this crater gaia
geysers out offspring
i am how justin roiland shouts
i am as a nod to renee descartes i think
therefore i
am a little spark of existentialism
similar to the simplistic but rapidly
evolving me seeks rick says
this i thought she was gonna [ __ ] an egg
there's a nod to the promortius episodes
a few weeks back which showed asexual
reproduction via
egg [ __ ] meanwhile jerry takes the
kids camping dad can we please go back
and hang out with grandpa's clay people
why because they might have a sega
dreamcast of course jerry's go to
console reference the freaking sega
dreamcast
the jerry of game consoles rick and beth
engineer a system to sort and develop
the clay children into a functioning
society they divert the lawyers
past the ethics tube and then there's
this interesting exchange why are the
athletes going through the introvert
sector obviously so they can bully the
mathematicians and give us astronomers
god you're such a space nerd i'm not a
nerd we're raising a society here beth
if we want them to be self-sufficient
they need to get out into space
so this is rick's and i suppose the
writer's philosophy on society they say
that the function of jocks
is to bully nerds into wanting to escape
this planet so that the nerds will
become engineers and then escape into
space
and that technology propelling all of
society forward and we see this
throughout the episode rick and beth
lead the clay people to develop
aerospace engineering and a generation
vessel to colonize other worlds but then
the ultimate jock returns the zeus
reggie actually in the end tag the
planets only add
listed athletes only suggesting that in
this universe
jocks merely procreate and battle the
nerds in order to make the nerds better
at making society better
actually i'm starting to sound like that
and so hookahsmoker
who was voiced by nolan north who is
coming in just a couple minutes there
are so many fun details in the clay
people factory they get syringed in the
butts that forces their mouths open in
pain
and their mouths are stuffed with like
nutrient goo the screens around them are
filled with basic food emojis including
a banana and apple forming a dick shape
of course playing cards show the new
suits of rick's culture like the three
of shits the four of skulls
there's a tic-tac-toe screen maybe like
the one in war games where they taught
the computer ai to keep itself from
annihilating its own world
the clay people pinball on a board with
round earth flat earth and middle earth
which if you think about it
is a fairly legit way to categorize our
society among
rational thinkers conspiracy theorists
and just the escapist fantasy
imaginative types who don't need to play
well with others we can play with
ourselves
phrasing they're sorted into careers
like laborers scientists interns medic
we've got an oversupply of teachers
putting a strain on the literary drive
activating playwright converter
and that playwright track spanx the
people and conditions them with screens
of angry people it's kind of a meta joke
by the writers that in order to write
drama you have to have been exposed to
abuse and conflict at a young age
there's a great dig at therapists okay
the therapists are getting bored we need
to increase their supply of incest porn
20
wasn't enough implying that therapists
tend to be into those freudian ideas
related to incest and based on the
teaser for next week it looks like
they're going to go back to their
therapist dr
wong who we saw in the pickle rick
episode how long have you all been
eating poop
we have never eaten poop
there's a category called unproductive
which includes djs foodies and
influencers
which backs up and blows up the human
resources department maybe a joke about
how the unproductive aspiring influences
in the office
tend to be the ones who disrupt hr
departments with like firings and
complaints
and they end this all with a great dig
at online colleges i can add an online
college work around or just push them
out through a pipe in the back
same thing rick maintains his factory
with floating drone mortys
suggesting rick has built a fleet of
robot morty laborers
to serve him like pasta butter robot
slaves jerry falls on a river and he
pinballs against the rocks with nature
kinda sorting him
before he ends up in the unproductive
filter along with him in the filter is
this stupid bag of marshmallows the key
to the
miracles he performs for his clay
outcasts dan harmon sings the camping
song
we get its montage intercutting between
rick and beth rapidly evolving the clay
people
to jerry devolving them into a
deliberately tribal state of nature
jerry gets these tribal tattoos of the
clay person heads and he tells two of
them in a sleeping bag there you go
guys pump those cheeks that's the
camping spirit
maybe it's my former boy scout days
talking here but i'm pretty sure they're
doing that thing where you strip off all
your clothes
and share a sleeping bag with another
camper to share body heat and prevent
hypothermia
which would probably lead to other
things and also that might have been
something they just said to me
and a little glimmer of hope here one of
the rejects defies his sortie to
actually succeed
at technological development building a
house sqweep
this is not a tent it is a new kind of
tent
with special gutters to funnel the rain
and a door it's a house it's named squee
which comes directly from the legendary
kavanaugh hearings
one of our friends skwee when he said
the f
word starting at a young age
had kind of a wind-up to the f-word kind
of a
yep that happened squee was a real name
i had to look it up it somehow wasn't
one of the parody ones
these beautiful creepy calendars
about lifting weights with pj and squee
and
donkey dong doug getting back in my lane
here morty and summer find a crashed
ship
probably drove through a nebula that
made them see their own fears that's
something not to event horizon
in which space travelers drift too close
to a dimension to hell
that gives them nightmare visions rick
and beth celebrate and rick can't
remember who elton john is
i'm pretty good when someone's in my
register like the guy that sings circle
of life i can't remember his name he
dresses up weird
god arrives but rather a zeus whom gaia
calls reggie
and rick immediately blasphemes this guy
swoops in after we raise his whole
civilization and tells us he forgives us
what a
mooch but this deity critiques rick's
human creation this city is a monument
to nothing
where is there faith yeah he doesn't
call it out but he's essentially calling
it the tower of babel from the old
testament the advanced city that god
knocked over just to punish men for
their god aspiring pride
i mean who is really the proud one there
don't smite me please but rick
absorbs the smite to triangulate the
source of his power and match it
got you now you son of a [ __ ] sweetie
you handle the hippies i'll handle the
off-brand yahweh
kick his ass dad bear witness notice
that beth
just pulled a 180 from telling rick that
they need to leave this god in this
planet behind
now she wants them to fight what changed
for her was seeing jerry show up with a
stupid camping army
and that this god aligned with them see
this is some ego she inherited from rick
who make her
too proud rick faces the zeus who has a
z
belt buckle for zeus and the greek
letter phi as a chess tattoo
it's not the alpha and omega that i
would suspect though he is not the real
god
kind of makes him more of a frat bro who
stands over rick to flash him
their fight is awesome it's a drawn out
brawl a bit repetitive but the episode's
writers compared it to
two sports dads fighting in the parking
lot which yeah it's just kind of sad to
watch
i love the thunderclap that they
included when zeus elbows him
and morty's ship controls do look a bit
like the video game controls with some
nintendo buttons visible
and morty paints on labels cd player
menu
elevation auto block kick pause
fire all and puppy okay
but of course all these controls are
totally wrong
in the battle jerry channels moses
partying the moat like the red
sea and he released locusts like one of
the plagues of egypt zeus
bests rick and reveals himself as a
petty old testament god who rules via
fear
the only lesson they need is right here
fear but morty and summer run their ship
into his brain like a bullet leaving
this
colossal corpse kind of like that dead
giant in anatomy park in season one rick
reunites with his grandkids we played
video games we got a high we did wrong
come on now you kids you did real good
here you did good
getting high and playing video games is
the best i swear to god
and i will never sell you out ever yeah
he makes his promise here but he
immediately breaks his promise
exactly when he just feels powerless in
the family later so he wants to corrupt
everyone and drag them all down into
chaos your kids got high on alien mist
and drove the ship into that zeus guy's
head basically murdered him
zeus's corpse crashes onto the planet
and paling on the tower the animators
included his bloody rib cage split open
and this is all making good on rick's
threat from earlier when i'm done with
you
you'll need a staff to un-part your face
and during the chaos one of the clay
people plays obi-wan to jerry
use the s'more jerry morty looks down on
all this carnage much like the guilt he
felt seeing all the carnage and the
primordius episode
oh geez that poor guy can you maybe not
tell mom and dad
relax it's just a zeus if this was the
real god it'd be a completely different
story
the smart line by the writers revealing
that rick is less
atheistically nihilistic than we thought
but possesses an
agnostic and healthy fear of the unknown
or maybe just the real god of this
universe is an alternate version of rick
who knows we'll see beth
asks i mean guy is not gonna raise those
guys to hunt us
down right oh most definitely i put a
tracker on their ship i'll blow it up if
they come anywhere near me yeah rick
says
me which isn't at all reassuring to the
rest of the family the post credit scene
was
the funniest of the season with rick
watching an ad for
planetsonly.com one of the planets is
covered in nipples
and they mention barely habitable
planets like
barely legal one planet is just a blonde
they tease their
holes in their ozones one wants you to
split his pangea into distinct
continents
making me suddenly very suspicious of
the marianas trench and there's this
quick text reading if you're looking for
a real planet who will value your mind
and not just your body
your cosmic queen awaits no fatties no
shorties athletes only
eggplant emoji planet rocket rick closes
his laptop as summer passes and then
tries to pass off this weird planet
campus just a comedic premise
something i'm sure none of us have ever
considered doing but before we continue
breaking this down with our special
guests thanks to
bang energy for sponsoring this video
every cannon bang is 16 ounces it
contains 300 milligrams of caffeine it's
sugar-free and has zero calories
yet it tastes really great there's over
20 different flavors to choose from one
of those great flavors
is purple guava pear
yep i'm getting accents of the pear and
the guava and the purple
look there are mornings where i was up
late the night before writing a full
movie breakdown
it's exhausting but a can of bang energy
helps pick me up so that it can you know
star
blast through more work there's another
flavor called star blast that one's also
really good
check out bang on instagram you can get
25 off your order at bang
energy.com when you use the code
newrockstars25 there you can buy cans of
bang energy including their sweet tea
and keto coffee flavors you can also get
clothing fitness supplements all kinds
of stuff to be your best bang itself
there are zero artificial colors and
they have a beverage that's called
stoked
that has broad spectrum hemp extract if
you're down for that
thanks again to bang energy for
sponsoring this video get 25 off at
bangdashinergy.com using the code
newrockstars25
and now joining me to discuss this
episode is a voice that we've been
familiar with for years
uh he voices nathan drake and uncharted
desmond miles assassin's creed
animated versions of deadpool a ton of
voices you've heard on a ton of shows
including rick and morty no i'm part of
the floaty nogasm brotherhood we believe
we're keeping him alive by redirecting
our suppressed sexual energies
i then of course he had left toys and
flesh drops for every one of us in the
spore hive
minds like these suck plutonium up to
the cities
where corporations use it to power
everything from diamond cars
golden showers and the more we remove
the more pluto shrinks there it goes
again
just shrank a little nolan north thank
you so much for joining us
oh thanks for having me man this is so
exciting and also joining us is
uh rick and morty superman and paternity
denier to millions
tommy bechtold hello it's not something
to be proud of
eternity denier i like that right
he writes all these intros for him list
any credits i just list
terrible terrible things that i do he
insists this is the only way we'll get
to know him and we're just like just
talk to us about your life
speaking of which eric i have something
i need to talk to you about after the
show
but we shouldn't do it on the air and oh
that sounds that sounds i owe you a lot
of christmas presents buddy
what papa oh no we'll find out
they had those clinics uh near my
college too
[Laughter]
you know everybody needs money for pizza
on a friday night so it was
it was it was it was 50 bucks 50 bucks
a visit but you could only go uh like
twice a month and i was like i don't
need 100 bucks that bad
i i had this theory that i could go in
and make a grand in about two days
and then i was like
look i'm just gonna need my own room
right
and it's nice and quiet
and this was by the way kids this was
before the internet that's right
yeah different times speaking of
paternity
uh nolan back in season two there was
that unity episode
which revealed one of rick's exes being
like a whole hive mind race and i
thought it was similar to this episode
which we get to see another one of
rick's
ex-partners it's an entire planet uh
yeah
and i believe correct me if i'm wrong in
that past episode
you might have done the voice of the
stadium full of rick's dads who chanted
go
sun go go
go yes yeah so
in my head and that makes you the
official voice of rick's father
so i want to know what you make of
rick's parenting i never
thought about that um well first of all
i was actually i watched this episode
with my
my my two sons and uh
it's funny because i i'm usually i laugh
out loud i mean i'm i'm nearly 50 and
these these guys are
you know teenagers and it doesn't matter
i mean this show is so funny and
last night just that's right you know
morning the planet
i i mean i i lost a lot i mean i i lost
my mind
uh just just it's this is a show that i
often have to rewind because i'm
laughing and i miss
the next next bit and it's written so
tightly it's
so you you and it's quick and i think
that's what i love about the humor i
mean it's so quick that
you know if you're not paying attention
you're gonna miss a great joke and
uh yeah uh yeah i guess
i mean i think rick's the best thing
that ever happened to uh to morty
is in terms of parenting because you
know sometimes grandpa has to step
up and teach you the ropes and uh
you know and you have to learn your
lesson like we learned in the vat of
acid
episode don't screw with grandpa
but in this one and this one yeah i mean
i think uh you know i this one was a
little bit near and dear to my heart
even though i didn't appear
in in this this episode just because
it's his lesson on video games
i mean that that killed me i mean i've
been i've been privileged to do so many
games and i'm just sitting there going
yeah you know what he just basically
said yeah that's it just play games
it was perfect it was perfect i do love
that yeah that's like his message
and you know for a second we think that
that's how he's going to be able to
pilot that spacecraft
is like oh it's just like the controls
how many movies and tv shows have we see
that
or it's just like it's just like the
controls and then immediately doesn't
work
yeah and she's over there she's like and
she's just sucking up guys he turns in
you basically
you're sucking on exhaust fumes i mean
yeah it was perfect
and and just just just to to debunk that
whole myth
like what do you think it's it's a this
is alien spacecraft do you think it's a
a game controller no that's right
yeah and and tommy i want to get you in
on this too because
i feel like what i loved about this
episode and this what the show does
often is remind us that even the adult
characters
and like the grandparent generation
they're all kids they're all like
immature and petty in different ways and
like what makes that person qualified to
be like
a god and lord over someone else's life
so like how do you feel about rick as
like a paternal figure to any of these
do you think he's better than uh well
jerry and that
it seems so he's definitely different
but it's it's so interesting because
you're like
well based on the like you know the
world created by the show
rick rick has saved morty life not to
mention the rest of the family
countless times he's also put them in
incredible danger
but he is intellectually and and you
know
uh uh scientifically more capable
of helping them so much more capable
than jerry
who's like you know jerry's basically
like basic human
urges and like he wants to be loved he
wants to be feared he wants to have
power
like rick is so much more sophisticated
than that so
i don't know that he's a better parental
figure but he's definitely
uh the odds of of success are far
greater if he's captaining the ship i
think than than jerry
jerry's jerry's useless right and that's
that's the great thing about jerry is
and as a father i can tell you sometimes
you
feel useless and yet and yet you
and yet you feel like you're responsible
to
come up with something even though if
it's [ __ ] i think the best thing i
ever learned as a parent is to just
sometimes go
i don't know right that's [ __ ] you got
to figure out yourself pal
come on let's go get an ice cream
seriously
i can remember you know i have two
sisters that were all around the same
age i can remember us like as a group
turning on one of my parents and like
you know just berating them for how much
of a failure
they they were like in a certain
situation on a vacation
and like watching that just made me
cringe it made me feel so bad for all
the times that like
as like a 16 year old we'd all turn our
heads from the back of the car and be
like you suck
this is the worst vacation ever it's
like god that must have just felt awful
i really like karmically someday my
children will do that to me but i i it
definitely
that part where where summer is berating
him
by the campfire really yeah it was yeah
the thing about that i think that's a
parent's worst nightmare
to be called out by your kids and
because the problem with jerry
uh and chris parnell who i've worked
with on other projects
as well is just perfect it's just voice
he's just so eager to do the right thing
and
do and it almost like that he's the guy
who bought the guidebook on how to be a
parent
and he wrote it and probably made notes
in the in the
in the margins and
like any parent will tell you you
you can make all the plans in the world
um you're screwed
if you if you go into raising a kid with
a plan because
everybody's different and i just think i
think that's what's great is that
he represents that father that is just
trying to
do the gosh darn best and it's like you
don't know [ __ ] man
you don't know [ __ ] and if you could
just drop your your ego enough
to and he's got a father-in-law who
calls him out on it
so everybody dumps on him and yet he
just keeps trying
it's just it's just a perfect character
yeah i one thing i loved uh one of the
writers said like in the behind the
scenes on this episode that um
basically jerry's big life skill is
camping which the writer compared to
just being homeless
like you know how to be like make your
own fire and sleep in a tent and like
yeah i guess that is what camping is
like
but i got to tell you i got to tell you
i that this episode hit home
in a number of ways the gaming the
different parts
but i hate camping
and growing up my kids want hey let's go
camping i'm like
it's we're where you want to go to the
beach we're gonna
you know there's there's rapists and
murderers at the beach you're not gonna
get in the water it's cold and then you
buy a shark
and you really want to sleep in a tent
your clothes are going to smell like
that
and yeah we can cook and my wife would
look at me going
you're just just ruining just the idea
why don't you just
go yeah just let them learn that thing
and i'm like
but it's you're outside there's bugs and
then it's like
it's and like i'll go all day out in the
woods we'll go hike i'll do that stuff
but
let's come home and take a shower and
sleep in a bed i'm with you
i worked so hard to make money for you
to have a shelter and a shower like why
do you want to be homeless right now
you gotta be sleeping in the car and i
have to clean all this [ __ ] up
[Laughter]
and the song oh my god the original saw
the camping like the 80s rock
camping song that they said even if you
hate it you're still going camping was
that one of the lines
yeah yeah well i got to ask you guys
because to me the craziest
thing about this episode is for a second
it seemed like they were going to say
not only is rick a god figure you're
going to see him kill god in this
episode
but they made like a super clever choice
one of the like final lines of the
episode where rick just goes if this was
the real god this would be a completely
different story
and i want to get you guys thoughts on
that because to me this show always
seemed pro
intelligent design like a version of
intelligent design by rick
or by dan harmon or justin roiland um
but to me
it like it was crazy to this acknowledge
the existence of some kind of one above
all
creator in this universe what did you
guys make of that line how'd you react
to it
i think i think i think they played it
really well i think uh
you know it's a it's a tight wire act uh
when you when you get into this kind of
thing
but you know they made they made that
character more like a zeus a god
not the god yeah and i think that that's
uh that's what you do
but you know i always looked at it
personally like this and and maybe this
is
this we can use this for this uh
purposes of this
talk but you you can't
you can't you know people say can't
prove there's a god
yeah but you can't disprove it either so
and
and i always used to laugh and go i
would rather believe in a higher power
because if i'm wrong and i die and go
somewhere and everyone's like ah
look
hey you got a little egg on your face
there there's no god
but if there is hey i'm a believer
but if there isn't you know and if you
don't believe and there is
you could be screwed that's true sorry i
just i'm just
i go pragmatic i'm just very logically
minded
so i think they they in this episode
they kind of go yeah
they acknowledge there could be and rick
is smart enough to know
it could be might not but
you can't prove it one way or the other
so leave it open and and that's okay
we don't have to have a definitive
answer right and that's a very i agree
rick uh a rick thing is to always have
uh cover your ass scenarios so it's like
exactly
even though this you know all the
science in the world and you know would
point to
there be an explanation for all these
things i'm not going to
being absolute about this point i'm
going to have once again another
escape plan whether it's faith or
whatever so
i think that was a very yeah it was a
consistent choice by the writers rather
than uh
you know a curveball yeah it kind of it
was one of these great lines that like
reminded us
what the character really is as opposed
to like introduce something new about
them
it's like i kind of felt when i heard
that i'm like oh right yeah because
rick as aggressively nihilistic and
possibly atheistic as he seems
at the end of the day he's someone who
like respects the unknown
and he understands that there are
greater things to
be in awe of and fear out in the cosmos
that like he has a healthy i think
pragmatism is a good
word for it as well he's got a very
practical uh fear of the unknown that's
which i like hearing that that's a good
way i love that i practical
fear of the unknown it's like yeah sure
something could
kill me out there something's out there
yeah
um nolan i've uh one of the reasons we
i'm loving talking to you is like and
hearing your voice come up on the show
over and over again is you just kind of
have the voice of like a guy who's just
like i'm just going with this
right now like you have a way to like
just normalize a confusing and maybe
like messed up scenario which
is so essential to rick and morty
because it gets so crazy
can you think of a time that the writers
might have handed you a line where
you're just like
yikes this is this is dark or this is
dense but yeah okay let's do it
you know what um i'd love to give you a
story but i
my mind is just as dark as anything
justin and dan have ever come up with
and i think that's why they hire me
because it's like
i mean i'm sitting there going you know
i can make this worse if you want
they're like no just read it just read
it
that's what i love about it but that's
what i love about this show they're not
afraid to go dark it's not afraid to be
edgy but funny it's as long as it's
funny you know you're not being edgy for
edgy's sake you're just like right
this is smart humor this is smart
edgy humor and it's just you know and
for people go
oh it's like you know no no don't stop
we're this this is a perfect time for
this kind of show because
i think we get i think people get too
safe and
they don't want to insult anybody or do
anything and rick and morty's been able
to
not really insult anybody
and yet it still just
resonates with everyone because it's
just we all have a little edge to us no
matter what deep down and just
you know and for those who don't like it
don't ruin my good time
don't watch but um yeah i i don't know i
mean i
have they ever handed me anything
now the the first i get a lot of people
i meet that remember me as scroopy
noopers you know pluto's
yeah yeah i feel that just got a little
smaller it's just like
just you know i remember that one uh
then a lot of
times i don't have a character name i'm
you know agent number one
or i'm just that alien have a
conversation you know like what do you
mean
and i i love that they they'll name an
alien like
you know reggie yeah you know
no steve that's not the way it works
and it's just there's something just
beautiful about the whole thing so no
no there's nothing i've never gotten
anything right because like ooh
of course i don't block it much yeah
well i think that's what makes you such
a good fit for the show and we really
look forward to hearing what future
voices come up on the show because it's
it's always a delight to hear your voice
and uh whatever character it is as an
actor it's so much fun to just show up
at this session because
i honestly have no idea what i'm about
to do
we literally walk in the scripts are
there i don't get them ahead of time to
read and prepare
you just kind of go in and go okay you
read the scene he tells you a little bit
about it and then
you just kind of go all right south
florida daybreak say hi
i mean they're like no just go here and
you're like yeah that's good
and it's usually they're very very quick
with the decisions on on what they want
to hear
and you just that might like and i love
the guys and the different actors you
see as you're going in and out
all the time like uh maurice lamarche is
in so many episodes because he's
he's got such a great voice just on his
own
but he can do so many things and you
know it's just
it's just it's such a pleasure to work
on so i mean i
i just yeah any time he calls i'm just
like yep
book it move things yeah they need me
i'll be there awesome
well it's been such a pleasure talking
to you nolan thank you so much for
coming on the show
uh that's this week's episode of
explained everyone big thanks to both of
you guys uh both nolan and tommy we'll
find out who all your kids are someday
fingers crossed uh you can get early
audio versions of the show by
subscribing to our ricksplained podcast
wherever your podcast you can follow new
rockstars on youtube on our socials
subscribe to this channel for more rick
and morty breakdowns and breakdowns of
everything you love we'll close out this
week with our favorite joke from the
episode i don't care who else stuffed
your crust but i'm the guy that showed
up
[Music]
you
[Music]